und jetzt das heute journal
hallo und guten abend hinein einen
gewinner des krieges gegen die ukraine
gibt es bereits in deutschland es ist
die rüstungsindustrie auf dem größten
amerikanischen luftwaffenstützpunkt
außerhalb der usa in ramstein rheinland
pfalz beraten 40 staaten über
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
deutschland sagt jetzt auch flugabwehr
panzer zu typ gebhart der düsseldorfer
konzern rheinmetall bietet gebrauchte
kampfpanzer an typ leopard und
währenddessen kommt aus moskau eine
drohung die gefahr eines dritten
weltkriegs sei ernst und real sagt der
außenminister gunnar krüger berichtet
die zeiten sind nicht nach glaspalästen
im club der offiziere trifft der
verteidigungsminister der usa
auf gut 40 seiner amtskollegen
ich weiß wir sind alle entschlossen
alles zu tun um der ukraine zu geben was
sie in ihrem kampf braucht darum reden
wir heute darüber in welchem rahmen wir
künftig zusammenarbeiten wir müssen noch
viel mehr tun
der tagungsort unterstreicht die
forderung rammstein ist für die usa wie
zu hause ist für die militärhilfe ein
drehkreuz ist für die deutsche
verteidigungsministerium die nächste
kehrtwende die so nicht wirken soll die
deutsche politik ist davon geprägt dass
wir keine alleingänge machen dass wir
uns eng abstimmen mit unseren alliierten
es ist uns ein anliegen genau da immer
anzusetzen wo die ukraine den bedarf
sieht wo die ukraine den bedarf hat nun
ist luftabwehr kein neuer bedarf aber
der gepard erfüllt die längst
ausgemustert bei der bundeswehr erlaubt
berlin nun die ausfuhr und zahlt dafür
nachfrage beim gastgeber in ramstein
reicht das
dieses waffensystem gibt der ukraine
echte fähigkeiten was deutschland in der
zukunft noch tut ist seine eigene
entscheidung die wird die deutsche
regierung allein treffen
nicht nur deutschland ändert in ramstein
eine liege die waffen des westens werden
schwerer und die usa führen dabei regie
die nato bleibt außen vor zu ihrem
schutz sagen die einen zu ihrem ärger
glauben die anderen es sind der außen
und der verteidigungsminister der usa
die in kiew anfang der woche eine
wunschliste abholen die ukraine erhält
nun hilfe von dutzenden ländern in form
von waffen geld waren und politischer
hilfe es ist russland dessen
außenminister sich daraufhin befragen
lässt zur gefahr eines nuklearen
konflikts
ich will diese gefahr nicht künstlich
überhöht es gibt viele die genau das
versuche die gefäße ernst sie ist real
und man darf sie nicht unterschätzen
was raunen ist was risiko das weiß nur
putin selbst der am abend den welt
chefdiplomaten an seinen langen tisch
bittet
ich verstehe sie haben beschwerden über
die ukraine aber aus unserer sicht
müssen sie diese mit den instrumenten
der un-charta lösen
ich sage es noch einmal wir führen in
den gebieten eine notaktion durch um das
leid der menschen zu beenden leider
nimmt der westen davon keine notiz kein
wort zu den neuen waffen des westens
gemeinsam hat man nur die
sprachlosigkeit
es gibt einiges zu besprechen gleich mit
der
bundesverteidigungsministerium die
deutschen sind ja praktisch über nacht
zu armee experten geworden
gezwungenermaßen ein land das seine
bundeswehr lange mit - ausrüstung ins
manöver schickte und seine
kampfhubschrauber piloten schon mal mit
vom adac gemieteten hubschraubern
trainieren ließ dieses land diskutiert
jetzt über waffenlieferungen schwere und
leichte über munition ausbildung und
panzer ein heute-journal überblick von
christian kirsch
[Musik]
jetzt also doch schwere waffen aus
deutschland für die ukraine der
flugabwehr panzer gepard zwei maschinen
kanonen können luft ziele bekämpfen also
hubschrauber tiefliegende flugzeuge
drohnen oder raketen die bundeswehr
hatte das waffensystem vor zehn jahren
ausgemustert die bedienung des gebhard
gilt als kompliziert
auch im gespräch der schützenpanzer
marder ein 40 tonnen schweres fahrzeug
das infanterie soldaten ins kampfgebiet
bringt hersteller rheinmetall hat den
export von 100 ausgemusterten mardern in
die ukraine beantragt eine entscheidung
steht noch aus
ungeklärt auch die frage ob der
ebenfalls ausgemusterte deutsche
kampfpanzer leopard 1 der ukrainischen
armee zur verfügung gestellt wird
wiederholt war von einem sogenannten
ringtausch die rede osteuropäischen
staaten würden direkt schwere waffen in
die ukraine liefern deutschland dann
deren bestände durch waffenlieferungen
ausgleichen
schließlich die panzerhaubitze 2000
standard geschützt der bundeswehr sie
kann ziele bis in 40 km entfernung
bekämpfen die niederlande haben
angekündigt mehrere dieser haubitzen an
die ukraine liefern zu wollen die
ausbildung an der waffe würde dann wohl
in deutschland erfolgen
christine lambrecht von der spd ist bei
uns die bundesverteidigungsministerium
vor lamprecht guten abend und nimmt
jetzt wollen sie doch gepard panzer
liefern an die ukraine die darauf
erstmal überrascht reagiert hätten sie
das nicht auch gleich zu sagen können
die ukraine hat zusammen mit der
industrie genau diesen antrag gestellt
dass jetzt die genehmigung auch den
export erteilt wird wir haben das im
bundessicherheitsrat beraten und so
entschieden und deswegen ist es für
niemanden überraschend aber es ist eine
richtige entscheidung denn es ist das
was die ukraine jetzt braucht das wir
zur flugabwehr dass sie zur flugabwehr
die entsprechenden möglichkeiten hat
deswegen ist das eine gute der richtige
entscheidung ja aber ich hatte ja nach
dem zeitrahmen gefragt denn die
genehmigung zu dieser lieferung wollte
der rüstungskonzern der dahinter steckt
eigentlich bereits vor zwei monaten
haben als der krieg begann sie wissen
vollem recht dass es international viel
kritik an deutschland gibt der ruf
leidet deutschland hat nichts gelernt
aus seiner vergangenheit heißt es da
bisweilen hätten sie all das nicht
vermeiden können den sie schneller
geliefert hätten also wir haben sehr
schnell geliefert aus den beständen der
bundeswehr heraus das was möglich war da
sind wir zügig an die grenzen gestoßen
es ist zu lange gespart worden und jetzt
gehen wir den weg über die industrie
über den ringtausch unterstützen wir
andere länder aber eben auch solche
möglichkeiten werden genutzt und ich
habe zumindest heute in einer sehr
großen konferenz in der über
möglichkeiten der unterstützung für die
ukraine gesprochen wurde dafür nur
zustimmung erfahren das ist das was
gerade jetzt aktuell die ukraine braucht
um den luftraum zu sichern gerade jetzt
aktuell sagen sie zeit ist essentiell in
diesem krieg wann sind denn die gepa
panzer dann einsatzbereich in der
ukraine
das ist eine entscheidung die jetzt auch
von der industrie getroffen werden muss
denn es ist ja ein vertrag zwischen der
ukraine und der firma wir erteilen die
exportgenehmigung das jetzt exportiert
werden kann das haben wir gemacht und
wir sind selbstverständlich auch
weiterhin unterstützen tätigt gegenüber
der ukraine dafür zu sorgen dass
ausreichend munition organisiert werden
kann ja aber die ausbildung selbst wird
über die firma laufen aber voller
brächte sie müssen ja auch ein
politisches zeichen setzen das sind es
jetzt wochen sind es monate wie gesagt
die entscheidet die ausbildung läuft
nicht über die bundeswehr diese
ausbildung läuft über die firma und es
gibt unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
auszubilden es kommt auch darauf an wer
jetzt von der ukraine geschickt wird die
groß da der stand ist der der der
vorkenntnisse um an solchen geräten an
solchen systemen zu arbeiten
aber ich denke das kann recht zügig
geschehen jetzt sind noch weitere
anträge auf waffenlieferungen schwere
waffenlieferungen anhängig 88 gebrauchte
leopard-kampfpanzer 100 marder
schützenpanzer kann es nach dem heutigen
tag da dennoch eine ablehnung geben und
zwar ist immer wichtig dass wir in enger
abstimmung mit unseren verbündeten mit
den alliierten in der nato in der eu
aber auch darüber hinaus solche
entscheidungen treffen und immer schauen
dass es sich auch ergänzt und dass es
dann auch in der richtigen phase der
fall ist und genauso werden wir auch bei
den beratungen im bundessicherheitsrat
das ist keine entscheidung der
verteidigungsministerin sondern im
bundessicherheitsrat genau mit diesem
thema auch beschäftigen und dann sehr
zügig jetzt auch entscheidungen treffen
das habe ich jetzt noch nicht verstanden
ist das jetzt ein jahr oder ist das nein
gegenüber diesen anderen
waffenlieferungen das ist die zusage der
prüfung genau so ist es glaube ich auch
verantwortungsvoll diese prüfung
vorzunehmen im bundessicherheitsrat ist
dass das was jetzt gebraucht wird passt
es zudem dass auch andere verbündete
liefern dafür gab es beispielsweise auch
heute diese konferenz dass nicht jedes
land alleine entscheidungen trifft
alleingänge macht sondern dass wir
abgestimmt lara ihnen unterstützt aber
sie prüfen doch jetzt schon länger man
kommt an den rat zu ergebnis auch
verantwortungsvoll solche prüfungen
solcher tragweite nicht übers knie zu
brechen sondern immer wieder auch sich
zu vergewissern ist es das richtige was
jetzt zu liefern ist ist es in
abstimmung mit unseren verbündeten und
vor allen dingen auch sorgt es nicht
dafür dass wir kriegspartei werden diese
bedenken sind immer mit zu beraten und
genau so machen wir das abstimmung mit
den verbündeten haben sie jetzt mehrfach
schon gesagt die usa der wichtigste
verbündete die handeln das thema mit
einem klaren satz ab wir liefern so viel
wie möglich und so schnell wie möglich
deutschland redet über mangelnde
ausbildung die der lieferung
entgegenstehen würde über munitions
probleme lieferschwierigkeiten
deutschlands kommunikation wurde als
zaghaft wahrgenommen und zögerlich kein
wunder oder er legt eine große
diskrepanz zwischen dem was wir tun und
dem die über uns geschrieben wird wir
haben sehr früh die ukraine unterstützt
aus beständen der bundeswehr
da gab es panzerfäuste da gab es
flugabwehrraketen wir haben thronen
geliefert wir unterstützen in ganz
vielen bereichen jetzt beispielsweise
über den ringtausch das in den staaten
in denen noch sowjet material vorhanden
ist dieses schnell abgegeben damit ihr
schnell unterstützt werden kann und wie
er dann aufhören also die unterstützung
der bundesrepublik deutschland ist groß
so war es und so wird es auch bleiben
aber vielleicht liegt auch eine große
diskrepanz zwischen dem was sie tun und
der qualität ihrer kommunikation es ist
auch manchmal sinnvoll gerade in solchen
krisensituationen nicht über alles was
man tut zu sprechen das hat zum einen
was damit zu tun dass wir gewährleisten
wollen dass das was wir liefern auch
sicher in der ukraine ankommt und nicht
auf den weg dorthin zur zielscheibe wird
und auch immer zu berücksichtigen
der feind hört mit und es ist nicht
immer sinnvoll alles was man liefert
alle karten offenzulegen um dem feind
dann
darzulegen wozu man in der lage ist und
wozu man nicht in der lage essen dieses
immer in der abwägung zu behandeln ist
auch aufgabe und nicht alleine darauf zu
spielen wie kommen wir denn jetzt in der
öffentlichkeit rücken sie sagen sie
müssen abwägen sie brauchen dafür auch
ein bisschen zeit die entscheidung für
die gepard lieferung ist jetzt aber
offenbar sehr schnell getroffen worden
mal eben gestern erst da war auch eine
menge druck zu spüren auch von der
deutschen opposition und auch aus ihrer
eigenen koalition oder dieser antrag
liegt schon sehr lange vor sie haben
darauf hingewiesen und wir haben
intensiv beraten und dann eine
entscheidung getroffen und das ist der
richtige weg entscheidungen nicht übers
knie brechen intensiv diskutieren ob das
der richtige weg ist aber daneben auch
konsequent entscheiden der bundeskanzler
hat seine bisherige zurückhaltung so
erklärt deutschland dürfen nicht
kriegspartei werden sie haben das gerade
auch noch mal zitiert das dürfe auch
keinen dritten weltkrieg keinen
atomkrieg geben das werden wir
sicherlich alle unterschreiben heute
droht der außenminister russlands sergej
lavrov mit der gefahr eines dritten
weltkriegs wie ernst nehmen sie das ich
bin so etwas sehr ernst denn wir haben
in der letzten der letzten zeit erleben
müssen zu was russland alles fähig ist
wir haben furchtbare kriegsverbrechen in
butter erlebt wir sehen die skrupellos
russland vorgeht von daher ist es ist
angeraten da sehr sehr ernst damit
umzugehen aber das darf einem auch nicht
leben in den entscheidungen und in der
unterstützung gegenüber der ukraine
und genau so gehen wir vor wir wollen
keine weitere eskalation aber wir wollen
konsequente unterstützung der ukraine
ohne kriegspartei zu werden und genau so
werden wir das auch weiter handhaben
christine lambrecht spd die
bundesverteidigungsministerium danke für
das gespräch und
das habe aufgezeichnet vor einer stunde
dann geht es ja auch noch um die
situation der bundeswehr um die
verteidigungsfähigkeit von deutschland
da hatte der kanzler ein geradezu
epochaler es umdenken angekündigt am 27
februar war das die stolze
zeitenwende deren umsetzung ist weit
weniger epoche machen da liegt die tücke
im detail und der kanzler muss aufpassen
dass seine zeitenwende nicht stecken
bleibt es geht um eine gewaltige summe
100 milliarden für eine lange kurz
gehaltene deutsche armee das sogenannte
sondervermögen das in wahrheit sondern
schulden meint es geht auch um die dazu
nötige änderung des grundgesetzes und
die dazu nötigen stimmen der opposition
dann getroffen
selten waren seine worte zuletzt so klar
und seine unterstützung so prompt
der bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten wir
werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr als
zwei prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
in unserer verteidigung investieren wenn
sie eine umfassende züchtigung unserer
streitkräfte wollen dann werden wir auch
gegen widerstände diesen weg mit ihnen
gehen der geist staatspolitischer
verantwortung durch die reihen und
disziplinierte auch jene bei spd und
grünen die höhere rüstungsausgaben
traditionell kritisch sehen doch bald
schon kamen relativierende töne drei
wochen später etwa an selber stelle von
ihm die spd ist nach wie vor der
auffassung dass zur kriegs verhinderung
mehr gehört als immer größer
rüstungsausgaben und schon gar nicht
gehört dazu
nachfolgenden generationen
vorzuschreiben wie hoch diese zu sein
haben genau diese haltung schimmere nun
durch clarke die union im jüngst
vorgelegten entwurf zur änderung des
grundgesetzes das geld heißt es hier in
diene auch der stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit neben der
ertüchtigung der streitkräfte
das ist eine formulierung die es so
allgemein gehalten dass alle möglichen
zwecke darunter fallen könnten also
beispielsweise auch maßnahmen der
zivilen krisenprävention also insgesamt
geht es dann nicht mehr um die stärkung
der bundeswehr und das ist unser fokus
und das muss auch der focus sein so
bestehe man auch auf der zusage dass
zwei prozent ziel dauerhaft zu
scholz problem er braucht die union mal
wieder bei der impfpflicht gab es in der
ampel schon für eine einfache mehrheit
zu viele abweichler jetzt ist eine
zweidrittel mehrheit nötig hinzu kommt
die union will wenn überhaupt nur so
viele stimmen beisteuern wie für diese
mehrheit nötig während sprich keine
ampel einigkeit hieß keine
grundgesetzänderung
das ist am ende parteitaktik und ich
gehe er davon aus dass die union auch
noch hier und da wünsche hat und sagt
das müsste vielleicht noch an der
unterstelle konkretisiert werden wenn
man diese gespräche eintritt kann man
das aus meiner sicht nicht mit einer
solchen anlage tun wir machen gar keine
taktischen spielchen für uns ist
entscheidend dass das jetzt umgesetzt
wird was der bundeskanzler ja zu recht
gesagt hat ebenfalls aus der opposition
kommt kritik ganz andere stoßrichtung
zwar ist die afg nun im kern für eine
massive stärkung der bundeswehr nachdem
er das sondervermögen zunächst als irren
bezeichnet hatte die linke aber bleibt
bei ihrer ablehnung wir halten das für
eine gigantische steuerverschwendung man
muss ganz klar sagen dass jeder fünfte
euro in der vergangenheit wurde
letztlich für fehlplanungen und
mehrkosten ausgegeben und da muss wenn
überhaupt angesetzt werden es dürfte
also ihr morgen wieder eine sehr
kontroverse debatte werden es geht um
viel um die zukunft der bundeswehr die
zeitenwende und erneut und die statik
der koalition
ja und dann heute abend die meldung
russland wird alle erdgaslieferungen
nach polen einstellen das habe gazprom
dem polnischen erdgas konzern mitgeteilt
polens ministerpräsident sagt vielleicht
versuche russland polen zu erpressen man
sei aber vorbereitet und auch bulgarien
meldet jetzt dass es aus russland kein
gas mehr bekomme und zwar ab morgen was
hat das für folgen dazu reden wir
zunächst mit georg mann er ist experte
für energielieferungen bei der brüsseler
denkfabrik bruegel
jetzt auch mal schön dass sie bei uns in
vielen dank guten abend herr sievers
polen und bulgarien jetzt also im visier
sollen kein erdgas mehr bekommen welchen
sinn kann das machen aus russischer
sicht
gm drohen stand jetzt seit mehreren
wochen im raum dass russland nur noch
gegen google zahlung gas liefern möchte
und das würde bedeuten dass die
unternehmen im westen einer
vertragsänderung durch russland
zustimmen müssten und sich damit
einerseits würde der westen damit zeigen
dass er dass herr schwach ist das erste
reihe dass er nicht bereit das auf das
gas zu verzichten sondern sich erpressen
lässt und einen so klaren vertragsbruch
russischer seitz mitmachen würde und
andererseits würde eine solche
zahlungsmodalitäten möglicherweise in
über weitere zwischenschritte dazu
führen können dass es russland möglich
ist sanktion aufzuweichen oder zu
unterminieren deshalb haben europäische
staats und regierungschefs klar gesagt
dass sie nicht bereit sind über dieses
stöckchen zu springen und jetzt wird
entsprechend ein exempel statuiert an
bulgarien und polen die potenziellen
kleinere partner sind der gasimport
mängel auf muss besonders groß sind und
die möglicherweise eben jetzt auch die
ersten sind deren monatliche
zahlungsverpflichtung an steht jetzt
auch machen lassen sie uns das
vielleicht ganz kurz noch auf einer
karte anschauen die pipeline um die es
da in richtung polen zumindest geht
heißt ja mal die kann 33 milliarden
kubikmeter im jahr liefern endet bei
frankfurt an der oder was heißt denn
dieser lieferstopp der pipeline für die
betroffenen länder und um vielleicht
auch für deutschland ja also es geht um
den mit den sogenannten ja mal vertrag
das sind alle lieferungen die polen aus
von russischen gas erhält ob das jetzt
über diese pipeline oder über andere
begrenzt geht und insgesamt bezieht
polen ungefähr 27 millionen kubikmeter
pro tag an russischem gas im vergleich
dazu über die nutzte mainz pipeline
laufen 170 millionen kubikmeter pro tag
also da daran sieht man dass die mengen
jetzt dran beschweren der vertrag mit
polen würde auch ende dieses jahres
auslaufen und die polnischen speicher
sind noch zu drei viertel gefüllt werden
die deutschen speicher nur noch zu einem
drittel gefüllt sind polen besitzt auch
noch ein flüssiggasterminal ein relativ
großes und plant zum ende des jahres
eine eigene pipeline nach norwegen zu
eröffnen die schon seit jahren in
planung und bau ist deswegen wird es
relativ einfach sein auf diese
russischen mengen zu verzichten mann
hatte das handy gesagt die frage ist
dann was bedeutet das für deutschland
und ich glaube für deutschland sind die
die mengenmäßig effekte begrenzt polen
kann sich wie gesagt an großen teil
selbst versorgen für deutschland ist die
große frage ob man eben auf diese
forderung der rubel zahlung eingeht aus
angst davor dass man auch abgeschaltet
wird oder ob man hier auch im sinne
europäischer solidarität dann sagt nein
also entweder wir alle zusammen oder
oder niemand das ist natürlich dann eine
politische frage hat sagt man erstmal
ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
kurzfristigen informationen heute abend
politische frage stichwort berlin
stichwort theo koll theodor smidt gehört
polen bulgarien die große frage bald
deutschland fragezeichen wie alarmiert
ist denn die bundesregierung jetzt also
ich hab ihn im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium nachgefragt
und da schreibt man mir zitat die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland ist
derzeit weiter
gewährleistet wir beobachten die lage
genau und die bundesnetzagentur auf
deren seit ich gerade war die meldet
heute die gasversorgung in deutschland
ist stabil im kanzleramt wurde man so
ist mein eindruck von den entscheidungen
jedenfalls überrascht die jamal-pipeline
ist ja wir haben es eben angedeutet
gehört zumindest von diesen drei
russischen gasleitungen in richtung
deutschland die am wenigsten wichtige
und den vergangenen monaten waren ja
auch die gas flüsse durch jamal immer
wieder gering bis gleich null
beunruhigen aber könnte oder sollte
berlin möglicherweise wirklich der
anlass diese stopps also die weigerung
der polen in rubel zu zahlen denn auch
die bundesregierung besteht ja weiter
auf zahlungen in euro oder dollar sowie
in den lieferverträgen vereinbart
daraufhin gab es ja wir erinnern uns das
russische angebot dieser zwei konten
lösung bei der gazprombank
unterm strich bleibt diese eiserne regel
die das russland immer gas liefert auch
in der größten krise
die dürfte glaube ich damit jetzt
geschichte sein und das wäre angesichts
der hohen deutschen gas abhängigkeit ein
klares waren oder auch sogar ein
alarmsignal theo koll seit der berlin
dankeschön und hier weiter mit weiteren
wichtigen nachrichten aus der moldau
region transnistrien sind von lokalen
behörden weitere zwischenfälle gemeldet
worden demnach fielen heute durch
explosionen an einer funkanlage zwei
große antennen aus gestern sollen
explosionen das hauptquartier der
staatssicherheit erschüttert haben
transnistrien ist eine vom prorussischen
separatisten kontrollierte region der
landstreifen grenzt an die ukraine
das bayerische verfassungsschutz gesetz
muss überarbeitet werden in seiner
derzeitigen form ist es nach einem
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichts
teilweise verfassungswidrig beanstandet
wurde unter anderem wie die regelungen
gefasst sind zur überwachung von
wohnungen observationen außerhalb davon
online-durchsuchungen ortung von
mobiltelefonen und zum einsatz von
verdeckten mitarbeitern
die bundesanwaltschaft hat die
ermittlungen gegen den kern der jet
gruppe übernommen die die entführung von
gesundheitsminister lauterbach und einen
umsturz geplant haben soll vier männer
waren mitte april festgenommen worden
laut bundesanwaltschaft geht es nun um
den verdacht einer terroristischen
vereinigung im zusammenhang mit der
festnahme der beschuldigten hätten sich
dafür anhaltspunkte ergeben
nordkoreas machthaber kim jong un hat
angekündigt das atomwaffenprogramm
seines landes auszubauen die nuklear
streitkräfte müssten in umfang und
qualität verstärkt werden und jederzeit
einsatzbereit sein wurde camp in
staatsmedien zitiert kim äußerte sich im
rahmen einer militärparade zum
neunzigsten jahrestag der gründung der
nordkoreanischen volksarmee
demnach drohte er auch damit die
atomwaffen einzusetzen sollte nordkorea
provoziert werde
die schüler von einst sind ihren weg
gegangen sie werden heute zurück gedacht
haben an den 26 april 2002 als der name
ihrer schule und ihrer stadt plötzlich
für einen amoklauf standen mit vielen
opfern 13 lehrer des gutenberg
gymnasiums in erfurt sind immer noch an
der schule auch sie hatten einen weg zu
gehen sie gehen ihn immer noch es war
das erste schulmassaker in diesem ausmaß
an einer deutschen schule die
geschockten erfurter sagten damals immer
wieder so etwas kennen wir nur aus den
usa es ist nicht das letzte geblieben
und so ist der tag heute natürlich einer
an dem der toten gedacht wird an dem sie
versuchen worte zu finden für diese
abgerissenen lebenslinien wie es die
schulleiterin formuliert die
schulleiterin übrigens damals wie heute
und an dem sich erfurt und deutschland
fragen müssen welche konsequenzen aus
dem tag vor 20 jahren gezogen worden
sind melanie haack aus erfurt
um 11 uhr läuten sie die glocke am
gutenberg gymnasium
erinnern an 16 opfer elf lehrer eine
referendarin eine sekretärin zwei
schüler ein polizist getötet am 26 april
2002 von einem ehemaligen schüler es ist
der letzte tag der schriftlichen
abiturprüfungen als kurz vor elf auf den
fluren plötzlich laute geräusche zu
hören sind ich habe mir natürlich nichts
weiter gedacht bis dann
unsere lehrerinnen die bei uns im raum
war
zur tür ist um zu schauen was da los ist
und genau in dem moment stand robert
steinhäuser auf der anderen seite und
hat sich schuss
knapp 20 minuten in denen der täter die
bluttat begeht und sich anschließend
selbst tötet stunden müssen die schüler
in den klassenräumen bleiben und stunden
liegen die opfer dort der 19 jährige war
wegen eines gefälschten attests von der
schule verwiesen worden die aus sicht
keinen schulabschluss zu haben das geld
später als ein mögliches motiv seitdem
hat sich in der polizeiarbeit einiges
verändert weil die trainings umgestellt
worden sind die weisung lagen umgestellt
sind wir auch entsprechende
ausstattungen jetzt bekommen haben um
solche taten oder solche ereignisse
besser polizei nicht bewältigen zu
können das gutenberg-gymnasium wurde
saniert das waffenrecht in deutschland
verschärft und in thüringen in der
zehnten klasse eine zwischenprüfung
eingeführt um vor dem abi schon einen
abschluss sicher zu haben es ist wichtig
dass es hier zuzüglich zur lehrperson
unterstützungsmechanismus gibt da ist in
den letzten 20 jahren ähnliches passiert
ich kann aber jetzt aus eigener
erfahrung sagen es hat 18 jahre gedauert
bis auch in diesem haus ein
schulsozialarbeiter etabliert worden ist
und das sind die mir die sind einfach zu
langfristig angesiedelt der 26 april
2002 er bleibt tief im gedächtnis und
ist auch ein erinnern an das was es noch
zu tun gibt damit solche taten nie
wieder passieren
so ist es harter schnitt jetzt in der
sendung und hans macht weiter
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck war
heute in warschau zu gesprächen über die
zusammenarbeit in energiefragen
dabei äußerte sich habe ich auch zur
abhängigkeit deutschlands von russischem
öl importen frank bethmann da hat sich
demnach einiges getan ja überraschend
fiel sogar in sehr kurzer zeit der
bundeswirtschaftsminister äußerte sich
heute mit neuen zahlen demnach ist
deutschlands abhängigkeit von russischem
öl deutlich kleiner geworden von 35%
abhängigkeit sind wir jetzt auf ungefähr
zwölf runtergegangen und 12 ist nur
schwedt die raffinerie im
brandenburgischen schwedt wird direkt
per pipeline aus russland versorgt und
vom energieriesen rosneft gemanagt das
geschäftsmodell des russischen
staatskonzerns sei es so habeck
russisches öl zu kaufen wenn wir
russisches öl nicht mehr haben wollen
dann brauchen wir dafür für schwedt eine
alternative und diese alternative zu
entwickeln ist aufgabe der nächsten tage
und ja ich hoffe nur noch tage bald
schon also das ist den worten zu
entnehmen sieht sich deutschland für
einen stopp russischer öllieferungen
gerüstet gut gerüstet schien heute auch
der dax über weite strecken des tages
doch am ende ging ihnen ein wenig die
puste aus dem handelsschluss gab das
aktienbarometer 1,2 prozent oder
168 punkte nach frank wittmann vielen
dank
wie kann die medienbranche vielfalt
fördern darüber haben in berlin
vertreterinnen und vertreter aller
grossen fernsehsender diskutiert das
bündnis medien für vielfalt zu dem auch
das zdf gehört erklärte diversität
voranzutreiben ist unsere gemeinsame
verantwortung
man sei dabei auf einem guten weg die
integrationsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung riemer labbadia gewann
forderte mehr präsenz von menschen mit
einwanderungsgeschichte in deutschen
medien
ja das war unsere welt an diesem
dienstag von unserem heute journal bis
morgen und um 0 uhr meldet sich
christopher wehrmann mit dem heute
schnell update wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter in indien ist derzeit eine
massive hitzewelle zu gange das sind die
höchsttemperaturen von heute bis 47 grad
ging es hoch aber auch in den nächsten
tagen vielleicht entdecken temperaturen
zwischen 40 und 45 grad kaum abkühlung
auch in den nächten nicht da liegen die
temperaturen die tiefs werte bei 27 bis
30 grad und im zuge der klimakrise
nehmen diese hitzewellen im frühling
bereits zu normalerweise würde man so
eine hitze erst im sommer erwarten ja
und diese hitze ist natürlich extrem
belastend für den körper und sogar
tödlich wir schauen auf das wetter in
deutschland da gibt es regen im südosten
es wird allmählich weniger sonst klar
des grösstenteils auf temperaturen gehen
nochmal ordentlich zurück temperaturen
mit minus 1 grad in der ostsee null grad
nach nordwesten und 6 grad im süden
morgen gibt es viel sonnenschein vor
allem nach norden und westen hin sonst
in bayern letzte schauer die lassen aber
auch allmählich nach und die
temperaturen erreichen 16 bis 18 grad
hier zum beispiel nach osten in 18 grad
am rhein main gebiet und 19 grad am
oberrhein die nächsten tage größtenteils
trocken und die temperaturen bei 14 bis
22 grad zb am donnerstag die nächsten
schauer und gewitter gibt es dann erst
am samstag damit ein verdammt